filled that in. I just discussed it with him after my call to you yesterday. And yeah, once you are available to just set up a call with him, you can let us know how that thing went.
Mm.
Yes.
Kip.
Hey.
So let me put the note here.
So, alright, let me go back to our...
record from the previous meeting here real quick. I know that you just updated me, but I just want to make sure, you know, like I have it.
I have it saved on my notes as well. So the backup you're still looking for, just so you know, I know that Charles is going to work on that day, but we just need someone to cover 9 to 5. It's just because like we have another team member also out, we can find, you know, one from our end as a backup. But you know, that's the reason why I'm asking if you can find one from your end that week.
Mhm.
Uh-huh.
Great. So on the phone coverage, it's going to be difficult. So let me see. I'm still debating if they even have them cover on the phone. It's going to be difficult for them to navigate things because they have to be very, you know, like quick at looking things, right?
Yeah.
Ohh.
So maybe on like at least maybe on the service request, you know, at least I would help, you know, that would help the team working on some service request that's already, you know, will instruct, you know, like in our document. So that would be great. And credentials that we have to talking about.
Okay.
But...
That.
Yes, so I think that the main thing that you need to check from with Jose is regarding that.
What is the time frame that you're looking for if a new credentials would be created for this particular engineer? And in the meantime, I'll just find out that who is available to just cover that for you.
Okay.
Yeah.
And then chairs.
Do you have anything else from the previous one that the action items that was pending on me? I'll just quickly update in case if I have missed anything.
Yeah, that's why we're going to go through one by one. So it does, for the first one is about a backup and I think that's good to know that you still, you know, like checking if that's possible. And I will check, you know, for the backup credentials and the, I think we can create one because.
Sure.
Yeah.
Mmh.
We have a backup, you know, like phone coverage, you know, like the account, you know, for whoever cover on the phone can jump into that. But on the phone, I think that backup engineer going to get lost. You know what I mean? If they're not familiar with clients, I'm sure they're going to be lost in the call.
Who?
Yeah.
And it's gonna end up, you know, like with a mess and all of that, so I just try not to like put all the pressure, you know, on that backup engineer, so just work on service requests and follow through, you know, all the steps on documents, so that would be easier. That's my plan so far, so yeah, keep me posted.
Kour.
for that, sooner is better. And I will get back to you, hopefully, you know, like we can just hop on the call or something, because our next check-in would probably be too late. So we can, you know, like talk in between.
Absolutely.
Yeah, just to see. All right, so next one is about a customer service training from for that one you say in progress for 70%, right?
Fifty percent has covered, and then yes, 50%, and the other one is we are spreading it throughout two weeks, and he'll be coming, I believe, half an hour early, so that he'll be able to cover it up.
Kip.
Fifty percent.
Yeah.
Okay, okay, that's already planned it.
Okay, let me put it that here.
Um...
Yes.
Fifty percent.
So.
Go to.
Team.
Start this too early.
Mhm.
To spend time on this training.
Press in two weeks, right?
Yep, that's right.
Okay, okay, so I think next check-in we supposed to have that task completed. Okay, perfect. So, next one is about the, oh, Josentro, I think he has to.
Yep.
He has so many meetings coming up and he's just checking if you guys can reschedule the recurring monthly meeting for every 3rd Wednesday at 1 P.m. instead.
Third Wednesday.
Okay, sure. Third Wednesday, that will be...
Third Wednesday, yeah, at 1 P.m.
Third Wednesday on 1pm. Just make a note of it.
Mhm.
So you can confirm to me later if you need some time to play.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
Snow will on my arm.
Kour.
Later.
The email that will work too, okay? The email, because the next check-in, you know, there's probably like gonna be in June, maybe he gonna he need that to adjust by then. The next one is about, I think this is new, so the whole team of ours, I mean the community IT.
Sure.
we try to pursue the Microsoft AI certificate. I don't know if ITBD has ever thought of that or any training that you guys have related to AI, that would be great. Because right now, we are, I mean, like for community IT, we try to pursue Microsoft.
Oh, okay.
AI 900, but end of June, they're going to release a new one, which is like AI 901. So.
If you can find something that's maybe related, or maybe it could be, you know, like relevant with the same objectives, that would be great. So this is not that urgent, but I want you to think about it if you guys have anything. I also want to make sure that ITBD staff.
Hello.
Also, we're trained with the AI technology. I don't know if you have ever talked about it before.
Okay.
Yeah, absolutely. So just wanted to appraise you regarding that. We already have the structure in place and every week we have a particular training wherein it is optional for the engineers because sometimes they are on call and sometimes they are not available. But yes, it is available for everyone. And I think Andy will be able to explain everything about what we have achieved in the
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
AI stuff. Andy, you are available?
Yeah, yeah, definitely. So, Nicha, there are two parts. There are two parts to it. One, what we are doing for our clients, and the other part is what we are doing internally. So there are some trainings in our LMS system for engineers, for leaders, available for everybody.
Yeah, so AI nature is asking about AI.
And there are trainings on demand also. And as Akhilesh mentioned, on weekly basis, we have AI weekly connect on Wednesdays. Everybody can join and they can see what we are doing. Everybody shares their knowledge. This is new, what I have learned. This is a new source which I have collected. So things like that happen in that call, weekly call.
And other than that, we have competitions also going on with regards to AI. If you have done something, made a project or created a dashboard, there's something using AI, you can nominate yourself for the AI awards and that's also going on. That's the internal part.
And for the external for our clients, we have already implemented more than 100 use cases where we have solved our clients problems. Like the number one was where we started was AI dispatcher. And then after that, QBR automation like.
from your tool, from your detecting tool itself, it will pull all the details, it will create your QA presentation automatically. So there are several other products which we are, AI products which we have available in our library and we showcase that, we share with our clients during our.
AI accelerator also, and we have AI by design many services now, AI many services which are available. So in that what you can do is you can browse through our product library and you can choose, okay, this product is what can help me and we can implement that for you. And we have a year long.
No.
A lot of options are there. So whenever you are interested, let us know. I can get a call. I can get a discovery call connected with our AI team and they can tell you more where we can help to solve the problems or the repetitive tasks you are doing.
Mm.
Ohh.
Wow, so you're offering me more than I expect, to be honest. But that's glad to hear about it, and thank you for sharing as well. For us, we just want to, I would say, like we tend to have more about Microsoft products.
you know, like Microsoft, like Intra, you know, ID, AI, I mean, not AI, I'm sorry, Azure or manage users, like admin setting stuff and all of that. And also, so many of us don't really know about AI that well. And we just want to make sure we are well aware about like what they can do.
what we, what we can, you know, like utilize them and what we cannot, right? So I would like to, I think that's really nice. I would like to see, you know, like, I mean, for the clients that you guys offer, I don't know if you guys have any, you know, curriculums, you know, for us to review first.
So I would like to review all of this just to see, I don't want to over, I don't want them to extend too much, you know, that they may not going to use it. I think that's good if they want to, you know, like to pursue that personally. But what I'm saying is like for work, I just want to make sure, you know, like if they have some related to work that would be helpful, that would be great.
So I'm going to compare with the AI 900, to be honest, for Microsoft first. We're going to start from there. Let's start from the foundation first. And the rest, you know, like we can, we'll figure it out because it's very new, to be honest. And I and myself also have to take one.
Me.
I mean, like, we just, this is a goal for our for us this year. We have to get this one like Microsoft AI 901. And yes, so I would like to review that. And if you can send an email, that would be nice. I will review all of those with Jose Antonio and then we gonna make a decision from there if there's too much for the team or not. Oh, but if that's, you know, some foundation, you know, skill that might helpful.
Why not, right?
So, thank you. And so I would expect an email from Andy or from Excel or how?
Nature 2 parts to it. First, AI 900 is a very good start point for the engineers and for the AI managed services, I'll have to check because the list is not openly published. Those are shared only in AI accelerators, so I will have to get that list from the AI.
Oh, yeah.
Mmh.
Excellent team. And one more thing I forgot to you, we have dedicated AI engineers also who you can hire just like Charles and all, and who will drive AI for your environment. That also is available.
Wow.
Some.
Wow. You offered and I asked for, but that's good to hear about it. I'm excited. So yeah, I mean, I don't mind, you know, share what you can. And I just because I want to share this, you know, idea with Jose Antonio as well. I just want to make sure, you know, like,
Oh.
Yeah.
not just only community IT staff, you know, aware about the AI. We just want to make sure ITBD staff are also, you know, aware of that. And, you know, like, I want to push them, you know, like, through another level, which is really difficult, but that's my goal. You know, just want to make sure they definitely, you know, how to work around them.
So that's the point. So Andy, I will write an email from you then, if you don't mind.
Yeah, next few days, next few days, I'll send one. I need some time. Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, no worries.
Some Nija has to do this for everyone.
Exactly, you're right, so, um, for about the...
Yeah.
But.
And for AI 900 that you mentioned, the nature, I'll just review it quickly and see that what is all they are covering so that I can help you out as well in case if something which is already being covered by R.
Mhm.
Oh, that's great.
Yeah, that would be great. You know, yeah, and it's the same thing. Remember when we went through the customer service training, you know, from HDI? HDI is the local, you know, like institute that provide the training for us to get certified. So it's the same thing if we can compare something that could be, you know, like...
Yeah, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep.
Kour.
equal to the same, that why not, right?
Yeah, sure.
Kam Hawaii.
Okay, that's great. Thank you. So again, no pressure, Andy. Share what you can. Share only what you have. Whatever you don't have is fine. Even me, I was looking for 901 objectives. They don't even launch, they haven't even launched it. And so like, how do I know? But by end of June, you know, like the 900, you know, would be...
gone. So Saba already got that certified, you know, so it's like very impressive and all of us is like, oh wow, it's been seen behind already. And so many of our clients talk about it and we have no idea about it. That's the reason why we just have to really like, you know, know better how to handle, you know, like all of those, you know, AI things.
because the expectation is higher from our clients. So I think it's very important for us, you know, like to get that maybe this year, you know, I think we already like delay all of those, but who knows? Things change every day.
Ali.
I got an update from you today. I also did AI 900 in February or March and now you're telling me it's been upgraded to 901. Mine will be expired.
Yeah.
Yes, I know, right? I'm just like, what? I just did it. It's a, yeah, so they say like there's more, I think they're gonna add more modals and all that because it's new. So everyone's just trying to like get it done and also they're gonna get a new one added. So Microsoft always does that.
Yeah, AI is changing every day, every week we hear a lot of new things on our Wednesday call. It's changing every day.
That's true. And I watch YouTube as well. You know what people talk about, like, the AI, you know, users, it's very less, you know, comparing what they can do. And I'm just like, wow. And it's more like video about, you know, how to AI this and that. I'm just like, wow, it's every day is a new thing. Like,
Every day is a new day, you know, for AI. I feel so behind already, so can you push me?
Ohh.
Hi.
Definitely, we'll share what we learned.
So...
Yes, yes. Thank you, Andy, for that. And I think it's good to know. And the one is about Murphy shift. Oh, I think we done with the certificate. Okay, that's clear. So that is about Murphy shift have changed permanently since we needed cap and all of that.
Already did that.
Yeah.
But still, Excel, to be honest, to you, I feel like even though the stuff doesn't say anything, but I feel like it's I want to consider like the ship rotation.
Kour.
Uh-huh.
Because to be honest, you human being, we need to sleep in the sun, you know, like down, you know what I mean? Like the body not gonna, body can work, you know, at night shift, but at some point, you know, you need, your body clock is different, right? So
You can't really force that all the time. I think it's longevity. It's better because I don't feel like the staff burn out and just leave.
Okay.
I want to make sure the staff, you know, like get treat as it should be. I used to work at the night shift before and I quit that job because I don't want to work at the night shift. And I wish I could have talked to my boss about it, but I did not because I was like, no, they're going to make me stay. So I don't want to wear a night shift. So.
Absolutely.
Yes.
Ohh.
I just feel like, you know, I asked Charles so many times, and he said, no, I'm fine working in the ship, I'm fine, this and that. But I don't know what exactly, you know, at some point, maybe he feel burned out himself. And I don't want that happen. I want to make sure everybody, you know, like, I try to make sure everybody is happy, but it's really hard to keep everybody happy.
But at least though, I mean, like, I still wanna keep that cheap rotation, so...
Sure. What I'll do, I'll just quickly connect once again with the team members and we'll propose a plan. Let's see what goes and how they think that that should work. And I'll let you know.
Yes.
Yeah, so I'm not going to put in a note for now. I just want to make sure, you know, I hear about your end as well. So I'll share with them and all of that. And I will leave that to you. And then probably, you know, we go to, you know, like we can just hop on the call and talk about it, how we can make it happen. Every six months is not bad.
But.
Sure, sure.
Sure.
You know what I mean? Every six months, I still can make that changes on ConnectWise system. Because if it's too often, you know, it's going to connect with the appointment and everything. So if I have some time to plan every six months, I think it's good.
Yeah.
Ohh.
Absolutely, I'll check for that and we'll definitely connect on this.
See.
Okay.
Ohh.
But individually, I think we're going to start with Charles first. Charles, I think he was out a lot in April. That's the reason why his ticket, you know, like number that he closed dropped a little bit, which is like not really a big deal to me. But what it's really like we talked last time, it's about the advanced ticket assignment, remember?
Kour.
Uh-huh.
So, you know what, after that, I have worked with him from time to time. I also asked the ticket coordinator and signed him for a challenge ticket, you know, like make sure he exports himself more. But what I got from there, I feel like he's still, he a little behind with the,
Mmh.
Uh-huh.
Communication. Communication means that when he drop an email, of course, he always double check with me, but I want him mature enough to like confidence, you know, himself about, you know, whatever he trying to communicate to client, he cover everything, the concern that the clients have and all of that.
Kour.
And he works his game very well, you know, with my, you know, like, with my help, right? But I just feel like, what if I'm not there? You know, I want him to be able to do it on his own and confident, you know, be more confident in it. So I want you to take a look with him about communication skill.
Uh-huh.
Absolutely.
Sure.
I think, yeah, I want to balance his like technical skill and, you know, like soft skill at the same time, right? So he has no problem talking with clients. But by sending email when explaining about difficult issues, this and that, it's very easy to just hop on the call and done it, right?
Yeah.
Hello.
But at the same time, that's not helping because so many clients are not available on calls.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's the reason why I want him to improve that skill, you know, like to just to make sure he, you know, like improve that writing skill, especially I would say, to make sure everything is covered and I know like tickets, you know, like a little bit deeper. And recently I found a ticket about...
The.
Actually, it's the it's a migration on SharePoint, so someone tried to access to that folder in the SharePoint that shared with all staff, and then they wanna move, they wanna remove the permissions, you know, on that particular file for particular, you know, like users and all of that.
Mmh.
Ohh.
So Charles recommend to open a new library because, you know, like that's what we recommend to do it because we don't want to break the, you know, inheritance permissions and all of that.
Yeah.
So once he moved that file, he asked the client to copy to the local 1st and upload from local to SharePoint again with the new library, which is going to loss the metadata, right? You're not going to be able to record on all the history of the file or anything. Metadata is going to be gone.
Ohh.
And that's the reason why the files seem to be generated from their clients only. So from this ticket, I feel like...
He doesn't really fully understand, you know, about this migration, how does it work? It's not just copy and paste.
Yeah.
It seemed very easy to think about that, okay, just copy the file to this and that, but it's not simple as that. So maybe you can, you know, take a look with him because the challenge ticket that we assigned to him is not just spam, fetching, you know, like, or security incident ticket. We also assigned him some complicated ticket as well.
Uh-huh.
that I feel like he's still like struggling. If I didn't check on that ticket, I would never known that that's how he did. And whatever the ticket he did before, I don't, you know, I didn't even go back to check like, oh, did he understand like correctly between like migration and copy and paste? You know what I mean? So.
Gaur.
I want you to, you know, like check with him. That's the reason why I want him to go get Microsoft 102 certification.
Sure.
because MS102 connect a little bit more challenge and I think he is going to help him with the analytical thinker, I mean thinking as well. Because it's, yeah, sometimes he just, I know that he always look for the basic troubleshooting, but for him to go a little bit deeper.
Yep.
You know what I mean? He has to analyze the ticket more and see different point of view more. Bring that to the table and talk to me. Not just bring the ticket to the table and ask me what, when, where, how, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So I, he's not entry level. So the question that I expect from him is different.
Uh-huh.
If it's Pooket or if somebody is like new to the team, of course, you know, like ask basic question is very, you know, or generate question is very common. But for him, I expect he brings something to the table first.
Absolutely.
before I feed him, you know, like a fish, right? I just don't want to fish for him all the time. I feel I have been fishing for him like so many times, or even I was there, you know, help him fish, right? But I still feel like he's supposed to fish something 1st and show me what he got.
And then, okay, we can share an idea what else that could be, something like that. So yeah, if there is something that could help him with the analytical thinking, that would be helpful.
Yeah, absolutely. I'll have taken a note and we'll connect with him like daily on this so that I can make him understand that how to go for the next level. I understand that analytical ticket is something which is required for the, because it's not only the basic stuff that we do when we are dealing with the ticket.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. Thank you. And do you have any feedback from your end about, you know, I don't know if you guys analyze or like review any tickets that he worked on and you feel like, you know, like something we can help for Charles?
No, recently I haven't been because I was out for quite time, I believe 13, 14 days, yes. So I haven't recently done that, but yes, I'll just keep an eye from today onwards as I'm full-fledged working. So I'll let you know whatever I find.
Hi.
Oh.
Yes.
Okay, yeah. So, that's the feedback about Charles, where's ticket assignment. I have been, I mean, since then we have been doing it and something I spot, I think I also gonna schedule some time, you know, like to talk to him like randomly about those, you know, difficult tickets.
Mmh.
Me.
because I expect him to bring something, you know, more. And it's not just, yeah, it's not just security incident, but I know that also like security incident that he worked on, that's a good start. But there are some tickets as well that he offered himself. Like, Nisha, I want to talk to Microsoft Support about this.
Sure.
Absolutely.
You know, since we cannot do anything about this one, he opened a ticket with Microsoft, which is good. You know, like he doesn't just like escalate the ticket. Oh, Andy, thank you. You're so quick. You said two days. It's not even 2 days. It's just two minutes. So, so yeah, so that's why I'm saying that about Charles. So if you have some time when you check in with him, maybe we...
Oh.
some difficult tickets with him just to see like if there is any roadblocks you know that he want to talk about that would be helpful. Because something that you know if I don't see anything you know maybe I don't mention it right but yeah I have to randomly check sometime. Like I said you know it's it just depends on the time.
Kour.
Maybe sometime I have time to do it, but sometime I'm very busy.
So, I would need help; I would need your help for that.
Sure, absolutely.
Thank you all.
I would mention that Excel will also.
Uh, monitor, you know, some tickets or maybe review some ticket review.
Yep.
And.
Perfect. And the staff development for Charles, as I mentioned, we already got, they already got, he already got a Z104. So MS102 is seem to suit him better for this year, and I really want him to get MS102 this year. And it's a little bit challenging, like I say.
Ohh.
But.
Sure.
It's challenging for a reason, so I definitely, you know, like want you to help him with that, to schedule, you know, a study and everything.
I don't know if ITBD has any training for MS102 there.
Yeah, we have the courses available, but yeah, for the test and everything, we'll definitely arrange it from the test. We have scheduled centers where they can go and apply for the exam and everything. But yeah, trainings can be done in-house.
And.
Schools.
Okay, perfect. All right.
Is.
Mmh.
I think that's all for Charles. I don't have any concerns, you know, about the KPI. I have been working with him a lot on the utilization as well. I think because of the ticket close, I mean the ticket numbers that he closes, you know, lower. That's the reason why utilization number also a little bit lower, but I mean...
No.
Uh-huh.
It's still better, you know, like we're working on that, trying to make sure it's reached to 50% at least.
Absolutely.
Yeah, so let's move to Murphy. And yeah, Murphy has been very helpful, you know, like doing 9 to 5 and his utilization number also, you know, like improved because I work with him closely about billing. Sometimes we seem to be under billing, you know, for our clients, so.
Definitely, you know, like check with him from time to time if he bill appropriately. It must be include the research time, it must be include the time that, you know, maybe they on the call. So what I have been telling them when they work on the call and they have to connect to that device.
Hello?
That already should be like 30 minutes minimum.
Okay.
Okay, so you can remind them again, like, well, you take some time talking to them. You're taking some time asking or gathering information about computer name, this and that. So that's already 10 minutes there, right? So it's not fair if we build only like.25, or I mean, like if we build 15 minutes, it's not fair because.
Yep, yep.
We doing research at the same time, you know, like we checking this and that. We also wrap up on the ticket, spend some time on the notes as well. So please, you know, emphasis them about the time spent on the call, especially, you know, when they connect to that device, not just the call, but following up on the ticket. So that one makes sense, you know, if they...
Kour.
Spend like 15 minutes, but on the call I want him to bill, you know, like 50, I mean 30 minutes, maybe.
Sure, sure. I'll work on that as well.
Yeah.
The.
Yeah, thank you. And the answer is great. You know, everything else is great. CISA score is great.
And I think we can, I think answering has been improved for Murphy.
Who?
We're concerned about his answer rate before, so I think we can close the loop here for the answer rate for Murphy. I think he has done better.
Sure.
This can be close, this has been improved.
Okay, and the staff development, I know that he's busy with his wedding coming up and you're going to the wedding. I'm so excited for you. I really want to pass along for a gift, but I don't know how. I'm still trying to figure it out. But anyway, so please enjoy the wedding for me.
Ohh.
Come, come, you can, you can come to the wedding. That would be a gift.
I'm scared. You know what? If I have a direct flight, I would go, but this flight going to India is gonna stop at where? Doha. And I'm scared, so...
No.
Yeah.
I don't know how long I'm going to stop there. You know what I mean? I don't know what's going to happen because Trump is still here. I am in DC. I live in DC. So every day is ambulance. And I'm just like, oh my God. And every day VIP, you know, like vans going on around. And they live on the embassy's
The.
Team.
Mhm.
street. It's like so many embassies along on this road that I lived on.
Yeah, mhm.
the road block, like, you know, from time to time. So I'm just like, oh my God, I really want to move out from DC. So because I'm scared. I don't know when I'm, you know, when something going to drop around here. So I'm just like, if there is a Derek, I told Murphy is the same, like Murphy, there is no Derek flight.
Yeah.
The connecting flight is always in that zone that I'm so scared. So, unfortunately, I cannot make it. So, please, you know, enjoy it.
No worries, I'll send you the pictures.
Oh yes, please, please, that would be nice. So yeah, just remind him after the wedding, you know, like, I mean, AZ900 is very basic one. It should take like a month or two to complete it. And recently I just implemented the planner, Microsoft planner.
Yeah.
Cool.
Mmh.
But.
just to follow up the progress for each staff, but I haven't really completely launched with them yet, but that's coming up. But anyway, from your end, you can also help me tracking, you know, with them studying as well. I'll prepare the exam or schedule the exam. I just don't want to put too much pressure at the same time.
Okay.
If they're ready, I wanted them to be like completely ready, not just ready because of, you know, the date is coming up, but yeah, so yeah, please help me with that.
Kour.
Definitely.
No, we definitely build a plan before just working on any of the trainings and everything. So that is well structured. I'll let you see the draft that we go through. So that will help you out.
So.
Oh.
Okay, okay, nice.
Bad.
This is June 26th.
OK, and I think that's I have for Murphy, that's all I have. If you don't have anything for Murphy or any questions, I'm gonna move to Poolgate.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, please.
So, Pugit submitted the 90 days review. So, you know, our process is like the staff review themselves first, you know, like, and then I have a week, you know, time windows to complete my review. And after that, I'm going to schedule, you know, the...
Hello.
the meeting to, you know, go through all of those, you know, 90 day performance review to, you know, like let him know about the rating and all of that, if he pass the probation 90 days, or if I need to extend that, you know, probation, that's the thing.
Kour.
But I noticed that, like, it seems to be like he's running late quite often, or is there anything going on?
Look, this is the actual thing I think he driving by himself. I have already told him because I've get the message two times in this week that he was running late. I've asked him to just come out of your home at least 15 minutes earlier so that you can be on time. So I'm already working on it.
he will be just able to manage it because he's coming by his own. So there shouldn't be any issues. Just coming prior to the shift.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, just, you know, keep an eye on that just to see, like, is that any problem? It seems to be like he's running late, you know, for some time, this and that. So, yeah, just help me check in with him, please. Because I am aware that, you know, I think it happened with Charles as well, like,
Kour.
The.
when are they supposed to be in the office and getting ready to log in, right? Because I cannot change that number for them because the time going to clock in by the system. So remind them that anytime when they clock in, it's the time that when they log into 59.
Yeah.
Mhm.
Sure.
So, give the number there, it doesn't show that they're on time. I cannot help with that.
That's right.
So that's the reason why you really have to remind him, hey, just make sure you log in on 59 on time. If 59 has any problem, let me know immediately. Because right now, I'm investigating the case for 59 issues. You know, like what do we have and all of that. So I can report that, you know, to 59 support.
Sure.
or maybe I report it to Jose Antonio because maybe there are the tools that would work better, you know. So we working on that, but at the same time, if they don't tell me, I would assume that they late.
So I can't wait to tell for sure if they're already at the office or not because I'm not next to them. So please remind them to log in on 59 on time.
Sure.
Kip.
Thank you. And for the certification, I don't know if you have, you know, shared with him about AZ104.
Just.
Yeah, so for that, I have asked him to just complete this communication training, that is the customer centricity, and then go by that afterwards. Because this, again, I'm just going to schedule it from the internal MDE team. So they'll work afterwards, after this training is completed. So one by one, we are going for that.
Mhm.
Support.
No.
Have you followed up?
Seems.
Yeah.
Yes.
Mm.
Okay, yeah, so no, this one, because he said he got a pump from the previous organization. That's the reason why. So I haven't heard from him since. And also his 90 days, you know, performance review coming up. We just want to make sure we have it, you know, on the report. Otherwise, I can't really say that he's certified for a Z104. So I just want to have enough information, you know, to.
Mmh.
put on the report. So if you can help me, you know, to get that information or the updates, that would be nice.
Yeah.
Sure, sure. I'll just talk to him today. Let's talk for this call.
Yeah, thank you. And these shadowing sessions, I don't know if he has been shadowing anybody. I mean, like Murphy or Charles.
Yeah, he sits right next to Charles.
Okay, do you remember the ticket that they shared with you? You know that, you know, like I sent you an email about spam tickets and all of that. So any feedback about that?
Yeah.
Hello!
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I have just checked with him and also just aligned that Charles in order to just help him out to understand that how things needs to be done over here. It's already on the process related things as well as the feedback that I have given him regarding the email that you sent out that you have something which was off from his end as well.
So he did acknowledge that and I'm working through it so that Charles is able to help him out. That's why we have just asked them to sit next to each other and get the help whenever required.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's great.
S.
So far, it's went well with the those spam ticket response, right? I mean, I don't know if he was if he have learned something about, you know, how to respond those, you know, type of tickets.
Yeah, yeah. So I have just set up the time with Charles as well so that he can help him understand that how to just communicate as well as respond to these kind of scenarios whenever he gets from the next time onwards.
Perfect. Thank you. And for pool gift that it's one.
Yeah.
I think other number, I'm not, I don't concern and it's really good. And also the amount of ticket he cost is 100 tickets. So it's 110 and 11. I mean, 111 tickets. So it's a lot, you know, and I told him as well, like, I don't care about a quantity from you.
Mhm.
I care about quality. So just please, you know, remind him that as well. I just want to make sure he don't rush himself to just close a ticket as much as he could, but no quality in it. Otherwise, you know, that's the reason why I'm concerned when I see that CSAT drop in April.
Yeah.
Sure.
Sharma.
I think, if I can recall, that ticket was about...
Ohh.
I think it was about communication, so...
I, I don't know if you have reviewed that ticket with him, but I really...
No, I have reviewed that all these, all those with Pulkit. And yeah, he mentioned about the two of them, which was related to him. And the other one, Jose already mentioned that it was not on him. So yeah, I did discuss with him regarding those. So that was the communication. And I also mentioned that
Right.
I know that the number looks great, but it does not have any meaning if you do not get the full attention to all the tickets. So even if the ticket closure is a little less than what you are doing today, but it should be a quality that you have to just give to the customers.
Exactly.
Mmh.
Yes, yes, definitely. And that's why I'm saying like when I'm not on a call with them, but at the same time, I know that intentionally he didn't mean to, you know, like say anything inappropriate, but the demeanor or the tone, you know, like the tone is also important on the call.
Yeah, yeah.
So I taught him exactly the same thing, like, you don't know what they've been through. Maybe they have a very hard day on that day. So just listen to them, you know, understand what they're talking. I'll try not just to think about, like, trying to find the actual problem, this and that, just to see what it is.
Ohh.
Kip.
And if you're not sure about making a decision, talk to me. I expect him to talk to me more. You know, like I said, sometimes he can assume like, oh, you know, this and that. It's very easy. It's nothing we can do about it. But actually, it's not true. There is a workaround for the case, you know. And I think he didn't aware about that. So.
Sure.
Definitely, you know, like double check with your colleagues, maybe that that might be a workaround for so many, you know, cases, so we never know. I think that's what I think Pugit, he's confident with his experience. Definitely, I could see that. But sometimes, you know, our clients' culture is different.
Some some clients are very like picky with the pronouns, for example, even though they sound like a woman, but...
Yeah.
they're not happy with it. So it's really hard, you know what I mean? So sometimes it just really, in email, we just have to mention, you know, they or them by default. So you can reinforce them as well, like, hey guys, so you never know, even though they sound like a guy or a woman, you know, like, but you don't know for real.
So double check the pronouns before you send them an email.
Okay, yeah.
But the best, you know, mention their name is the best. You know what I mean? Like, because you don't know their pronouns, so don't, you know, gender thing is really, you know, like sensitive here. So pick the name, yeah, pick the name is the best, you know, it's the safest. So I remind the team the same, but
Yes, yes, absolutely.
Hopefully, you know, like, you can remind him, too.
Sure, sure.
And I think Murphy, that's all I concern. And what I'm working on is just about 90 days. And I think that's all I have for Popkin. Do you have anything else for Popkin that you see?
No, so on the back of that spam tickets as well as the communication. So we have another.
Kour.
Mhm.
topic or module for that particular training so that he is getting benefited from that and the gender bias thing that you have mentioned. So I had that experience and one of the other client as well. So that was that was some eye opener for me. So I got that.
No.
thing to other team members as well. But yeah, that's good to just have it reconfirmed with every other engineer so that they are following the process because definitely it's very sensitive. Yeah.
Yes.
Yes, so also like we try not to use the word that users, you know what I mean? Users could be mean like a drop user, you know what I mean? So I mean like, like I say, people here are very sensitive, you know, like with the language. So be careful. I mean, most of the time when...
Yeah.
Mmh.
I mentioned someone in email, I put the name, you know, I don't even use the pronouns because I'm not sure about the pronouns, so I just use their first name, you know, that's the safest. It's the same thing, you know, when we mentioned about you said this, you said that, it's especially on calls, you know, like just avoid doing that, or maybe just call clients instead.
Yeah.
Maybe it's better, but I think it's just it's just about, you know, like the culture. I hope you know, like, um, who will get, you know, about how do we work around the clients, because we have tons of them, you know, they have different cultures, they have different, you know, like...
Ohh.
Sure.
traditionals and all of that. So we're just trying to make sure, you know, like we treat them, you know, like as much as we could.
Sure, absolutely.
I think that's all I have. I know that I use every minute of the meetings. Sorry.
I think you have read a lot.
No, that's fine, perfectly. That's why we have just set it up for one hour.
Andy, as well. Well, thank you, Andy, for like hanging, you know, there with me.
Andy just switched off his camera. Actually, I just removed my cab so that Andy does not feel alone on this.
Had a lot.
Oh.
That's so nice of you, very thoughtful.
No, thank you. I've just got all the notes and we'll work on that and we'll send you the progress report as well that what we have all done and what is in track. Yeah.
Yes, thank you. And thank you, Andy, for the email. I got to need some time to review to get back to you because now it's my turn. Because I have to talk to Jose Antonio first, you know, like I said, it's not really urgent, you know, like to complete it soon, but if we can get it done by this year, that would be great. So
Yeah, thank.
Kip.
Mmhm.
The.
Thank you. Thank you, Excel, for today and Andy.
Absolutely, and Andy is so fast, once you just send him out a reply, you will get it after 2 minutes, whatever you require.
Perfect, 2 minutes, perfect.
Your needs.
Okay, perfect. Thank you, Vishal.
Nisha, whenever you plan to visit Chandigarh or Amritsar Golden Temple, let me know. I can be your food guide. I know every place where you get good food.
Andy, don't say that, because it's so hard to, like, take, you know, not to take the offer.
Ohh, yes, yes, yes, I...
Thanks.
I did not mention it and I completely forgot about that. Andy is our go-to guy. Whenever we visit the Chandigarh office, so he's the one who just helps us with very tasty foods. So yes.
Andy, I need your phone number. I think this is going to be personal request. So I think I plan to visit, you know, like my friends in Delhi for so many times that I used to work with her in Thailand. So, but I haven't seen her for 10, 12 years. She already got a daughter.
Yeah.
No.
Oh.
I will feel safe, you know, like to fly, yeah, so definitely, Andy, thank you for your offer, and that was so kind of you, and I will definitely, I'm so down with the food, you know.
It.
Perfect.
Thank you. Thank you, Vansh. Thank you, Nisha. See you soon. Bye bye.
Thank you, thank you, Jeff. Thank you, Abby. Bye, bye.
Thank you. Have a good one. Bye.